هذه صور مباشره مشاهدينا من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم كما نشاهد الان مراسل
العربيه اسفل الشاشه في هذا الخبر وشريط
الاخبار العاجله يقول بان طيران الجيش شن
غارات على مواقع للدعم السريع بمحيط
القياده العامه اضاف كذلك ايضا بان هناك
دوي لاطلاق مضادات ارضيه تابعه للدعم
السريع في محيط القياده العامه بالعاصمه
السودانيه عفوا بالعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ايضا طيران الجيش كما ننقل عن
مراسل العربيه بانه شن غارات على مواقع
للدعم السريع بمحيط القياده العامه الدعم
السريع بدوري كان قد اكد بان الجيش هاجم
قوته في منطقه كافوري بالخرطوم بحري
بالطيران
والمدفعيه مراسل العربيه يؤكد بان طيران
الجيش استهدف تمركزات للدعم السريع في
منطقه صالحه بام درمان اذن الجيش يستهدف
تمركزات للدعم السريع في منطقه صالحه
باندرمان كل هذه الانباء تاتي والسودان
يعني يعيش هدره وصفت بانها هدنه هشه تم
اختراقها في اكثر من مناسبه الان مراسله
للعربيه يؤكد بان طيران الجيش
استهدف
تمركز للدعم السريع في منطقه صالحه
ام درمان هذه
ايضا كل الاخبار التي تاتي من الخرطوم حتى
اللحظه وهذه الصوره مباشره
امامنا للسودان والتي تعيش الحرب في يومها
الثالثه عشر اعمده الدخان تتصاعد وربما
اعمده الدخان الكثيفه غطت سماء
العاصمه منذ اسبوعين ولا زالت
اعمده الدخان واسئله اللهب اذا في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم واضحه امام العيان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات